candid truth hi everybody and welcome
back to candid truth if you're new here
I'm Aubrey Jenny and we are going to be
covering today Valentine's Day let's
dive into this Valentine's Day is
actually known as Looper CIA the word
February in and of itself comes from
februum meaning purification it also has
the word februa in it which are whips
made from sacrificial goats which were
symbols of fertility and and strength we
will come back to that one because it's
a very interesting connection why do
whips have anything to do with
Valentine's Day you might ask we're
going to get there so the Feast of
lupercalia was what it was called it was
actually celebrated originally on
February 15th and young men called Luper
Kai lerai ran through the streets
whipping women with strips of goat hide
called februa women eag ly participated
believing that being struck by the whips
would increase fertility and ease
childbirth here is an article from the
Templeton Honors College it actually
talks about why candy hearts and bloody
knives the weird history of Valentine's
Day this says our Story begins as so
many stories do in ancient Rome where
the Festival of Luper CIA was celebrated
every year on The Ides of February l CIA
from the Latin lupus for Wolf and kidus
for hot the hot wolf Festival it was a
fertility Festival that marked the
beginning of Spring in the
Mediterranean a special class of priests
called the luai sacrificed goats and a
dog to fonus and other Roman fertility
Gods then two of the lupri approached
the altar where their foreheads were
touched with the bloody knife and
cleaned with milk finally the two lerai
cut the hides of the sacrificial animals
and fashioned them into whips then ran
naked through the streets of Rome
whipping the women they passed by a
touch of the Luper Calia whip was
believed to Grant a woman fertility
until the next year so there you have it
that's where the whip comes in that's
why it's a part of things as you will
see it gets a little deeper than that
and we'll get to the root of what
Valentine's Day and Lua Calia is really
all about they continue Shakespeare
enthusiasts and Roman history Scholars
May recognize the Ides of February as
significant in the life of Julius Caesar
Mark Anthony tried to crown him with a
laurel wreath three times at the Luper
Calia Festival in 44 BC an event
dramatized in Shakespeare's Julius
Caesar the display didn't sit well with
the Roman senate who began plotting to
assassinate Caesar a month later on the
Ides of March the festival was held at
the lupercal cave where ramulus and
Remis were said to have been nurtured by
the She Wolf now we'll get into this
it's two young baby boys twins who were
in the wilderness and said to have been
raised and nurtured by this wolf who's a
mother you might ask where did these
children come from well let's cover that
according to Roman mythology Romulus and
Remis were born to Ria Sylvia a Vestal
virgin if you have not heard of Vestal
virgins I had mentioned them before I
yet to cover it all by itself but please
look through my other videos so you can
go back and figure out what those
vegetable virgins are I will tell you
that they were a group of usually 16
women that were chosen from Elite
families to be giving their life for
several years straight to the service of
the temple the Pagan Temple to Vesta
and they were supposed to keep the the
flame alive that protected the luck of
defending the The Fortress of the city
people's lives uh fortunes and luck with
the gods everything so their Chastity
their virginity keeping their virginity
alive or being chased fully was their
prerogative and to keep this flame alive
and if they didn't keep their virginity
well they would have all kind kinds of
punishments that they would go through
so they weren't allowed to have children
they weren't allowed to be pregnant so
this was their mother getting back to
the story ramulus and Remis had a mother
that was a Vestal Virgin and so she had
to give them up she was the daughter of
numor the rightful king of Alba longa so
that's just a historical text from a
historian of that day and it says that
Ria Sylvia was a priestess of Vesta the
Roman goddess of the heart home and
family I've spoken about her before it
says right here dionis of helic carnosus
wrote that as a Vestal Virgin she was
sworn to celibacy meaning she was
forbidden to have children however she
became pregnant with the twins Romulus
and Remis which led to her downfall also
a note on this which is interesting if
you're thinking like I am I'm I grew up
with Star Trek the only thing that keeps
flashing my mind when I say ramulus
is the romulans the the alien romulans
Commander Tomo as I'm sure you already
know we were responding to warnings of
Romulan incursions at nelana 3 I have to
laugh a few times because that's what
I'm hearing let's go back who was the
father there are two versions of this
story one says that it's Mars the God of
War the most common versions say this
and that the God of War seduced or in
some versions forcibly impregnated Ria
Sylvia making ramulus and Remis demigods
some variations suggest that it was not
Mars but a mortal man who impregnated
her or that she was tricked either way
here is where they have introduced the
idea of them being demigods yes they
were considered gods Ria Sylvia's Uncle
Ulus had overthrown her father numor to
take the Throne of albalonga to prevent
num's bloodline from continuing amulius
forced Ria Sylvia to become a Vestal
Virgin ensuring that she would never
have children when she gave birth to
ramulus and Remis amulius saw them as a
threat to his Rule and ordered the
babies to be drowned in the Tyber River
how did they survive the infants were
placed in a basket and set a drift on
the Tyber but instead of drowning they
were saved by the river god tber
it's interesting because if you are
hearing this it sounds like Moses right
to save his life he was set a drift in a
basket and the river Gods which which is
what the Egyptians thought the river
Gods saved
him and the Pharaoh the pharaoh's
daughter even said that the river has
given me a son there's that overlap I'm
sure they're thinking yeah our story of
ramulus and Remis is just like Moses but
is the more accurate one it's the true
story of the Gods so there's the
counterfeit there that last paragraph
there says they eventually washed ashore
and were nurtured by a She Wolf named
Lupa in a cave before being found and
raised by a Shepherd named fulus and his
wife the Festival of lalia honored fonus
which is actually called luus it's a
Roman fertility God often associated
with the Wilderness Shepherds and the
protective Spirit of the wolf now as
they got older you see ramulus himself
was said to have been deified after his
death similar to how Augustus later
claimed Divine status himself as you
look at the history of how Rome was
founded it was founded by Romulus and
Apollo's influence came later through
Greek influence there's a huge
connection here this is from Botanica
and it says almost 3,000 years ago the
Roman Empire was born here in central
Italy on the site by the river Tyber
nestling among Seven Hills does that
sound familiar Seven
Hills yeah yeah it
should the city of Rome where the
Vatican
is is nestled on Seven Hills a dramatic
story is said to have taken place here
all those years ago between twin
brothers called Romulus and Remis it had
been predicted that the two brothers
would become Mighty leaders but they
were the victims of an evil plot their
power crazed Uncle great uncle ordered
that the babies should be drowned yet
miraculously they were washed up on the
banks of the Tyber a She Wolf took it
upon herself to care for the twins
suckling them and thus giving them the
strength to survive the She Wolf Remains
the symbol of the Roman Empire to this
day
interesting it meant that much to them
that they made it the symbol of their
day and to this day it still survives
that way it became the symbol of Rome an
Empire which over the next centuries was
to exert its influence across the known
World primarily through expansionist
Wars but the Empire experienced its
first war a conflict between the
brothers ramulus and Remis at the very
founding of its capital in a of piku
Remis leaps across the provisional City
wall which his brother had erected
Romulus cannot tolerate this act of
provocation and slays his own brother
the founder of Rome thus made one thing
clear from the start anyone attempting
to breach the fortifications of Rome
would be severely punished he said those
who violate the laws of Rome will meet
the same fith
as my brother so I always like to read a
few of these from different sources to
start putting together some more of the
details and so we have not just that
they were supposedly raised by this She
Wolf but that this symbol now and the
statue has become the symbol of Rome to
this day and that she was suckling them
at her breasts to keep them alive and
that they became enemies because of this
um that ramulus was chosen and deified
and supposedly more special set apart
for this Mission um and Remis was not
and when he chose to create this wall
that
separated the city of Rome already Remis
jumped over the wall and he said those
who violate the laws of Rome will meet
the same fate as my brother and he
killed him so does that stand true today
and what we see with the Roman Catholic
Church throughout history those who
oppose them in all cases they have
always threatened and killed and moved
out of their way so it started then and
I'm sure that's become their motto but
it started um not just with him by the
way but he founded R obviously was a a
huge key player in this and so on the
found ings of his own brother's blood
Rome was made its capital and a great
City so going back to lubri Calia which
we said was originally on the 15th of
February what happened on that day is
that the sacrifice of goats and dogs was
believed to purify Rome removing evil
spirits and ensuring good health for the
coming year the running and whipping
symbolized driving out
impurities much like other Roman
cleansing
rituals the festival marked the
transition from Winter to spring so this
is another Solstice Equinox Festival
time periods which the Bible says not to
be observers of times like this I'm not
sure why I mean everything I know why
that everything is about their solstices
and equinoxes but just to make it clear
this is another one of those the
festival marked transition from winter
to Spring a Time associated with renewal
and fertility Romans believed that
impurity and bad Omens could bring
disease infertility or poor
harvests many Roman religious festivals
included some form of sacrifice
cleansing or symbolic renewal to
maintain Divine favor by sacrificing
animals spreading their blood and
engaging in ritualistic running and
whipping Romans believed they were
cleansing society and ensuring fertility
for individuals and the land here we can
see that it is being associated with the
whole entire well-being of Rome the
entire land and its fertility its
Harvest it's thriving in success and so
we have that kind of weight being put on
these Vestal virgins for one but your
participation in this would then be
pretty crucial to this having the land
be under good morale fortune and
blessings from the gods in reality and
we have to look at reality what
Valentine's Day is is a fertility and
purification ritual we just read about
it this is what they told us we do come
to that realization that it is a
fertility and purification ritual and
festival for doing so for everyone so
what God has to say about this other
than the other verses I have brought up
it says in Jeremiah 10 2-4 thus sayith
the Lord learn not the way of the
Heathen and be not dismayed at the signs
of Heaven for the heathens are dismayed
at them it's not just talking about the
heavens as though you look at them and
you think they're beautiful and Marvel
at
them their solstices and equinoxes were
all following
astrology and
that means that you worship the stars
and you follow the stars and everything
is dictated by the Stars you divine or
tell the future with them and um give
people's fortunes based on them and
everything and they are dis made by them
it's everything to a lot of them so we
are not to be like that Deuteronomy 12
verse3 take heed to thyself that thou be
not snared by following them
after that they be destroyed from before
thee and that thou inquire not after
their
gods and of course this is also talking
about the foreign peoples around them in
the
Bible that were tied down or snared by
these gods in their worship and that we
are not to do ask how did they worship
these gods and we're going to do the
same what we've had we've come to as a
society today for a long time actually
since it was instituted by the Roman
Catholic Church the red heart the
balloons the color red the Roses
giftgiving wine drinking you know the
festivities that it has
incurred why is that how did we get the
word Valentine even associated with this
well in
496 ad Pope gasius the first declared
clared February 14th one day before the
regular Festival held in
Antiquity as St Valentine's Day
replacing the Pagan festival with a
Christian holiday supposedly Christian
honoring St Valentine who was a martyr
associated with love and
compassion he conducted secret marriages
in the dead of night for those truly in
love and did good deeds in his
community now one might ask as well how
did cupid get
Associated that is this next part here
the story of cupid the Roman god of love
also connects to Valentine's Day because
he is associated with desire romance and
matchmaking Cupid's role as a
mischievous love deity aligns with the
themes of love and passion celebrated
during lupre Calia and later Valentine
day now right there adding Cupid into
this whole mix that is due to the Greeks
coming with
their um it is the Roman god of love but
it was more influenced by their also
mimicking the Greek gods who brought in
more of this drinking and marryt and um
sexual
stuff and so
there's this connection they had a God
that was similar and many others that
followed and so it was kind of wrapped
into a package together with the
original um origins of Valentine's Day
based on ler Calia and the lupercalia
cave and the shewolf and the two twin
brothers and the
whipping and then you have this wrapped
into it suddenly it becomes painted over
with a story of St
Valentine and because he was just good
willed towards people who wanted to be
in love he conducted secret marriages so
then all of a sudden he's a wonderful
guy and does good deeds in his
community um and then You' got Cupid
being wrapped together in that as well
so it's a mixed bag and um not
really at all what it used to be um even
though because it's held on that day and
it's still the same thing we I mean does
that make it
okay no um a holiday is Holy it's a
called a holy day to the Roman Catholic
church and when they made it world or
national a national holiday or
worldwide they just made it uh Global
worship if you will and um that is one
of that was their
intention they like that
so just because it's been given a new
package a new
exterior and said
intention
um and meaning does that make it
right I will leave that to you guys
Cupid a little more on him he was a
winged boy with a bow and an arrow his
arrows were
magical those struck by them will fell
deeply in love cupid is the Roman
counterpart of the Greek god Aeros there
you go though in earlier myths cupid is
traditionally said to be the son of
Venus goddess of love and beauty and
Mars the God of War this combination
symbolizes symbolizes the idea that love
which is Venus and conflict Mars are
closely
linked as love can often be
unpredictable passionate and even
chaotic so how did the heart become the
symbol this has been one of my questions
as well as several others how did the
heart become the symbol um and there is
a a reason there's a very definite
reason the heart has long been
associated with emotion love and the
soul ancient Greeks and Romans believed
emotions especially love and passion
came from the heart rather than the
brain in some ancient cultures the
symboli or stylized heart shape
resembled Ivy or fig leaves which were
symbols of fertility and enduring love
in the medieval and Renaissance ages
people started associating the heart
shape with romantic love especially in
poetry and art now I will add that those
heart-shaped leaves in most cases are
also an
aphrodesiac and a summary here Romulus
and Remis was lubric Calia which
included and was about fertility and
love themes apparently lubric calia's
romantic and fertility
elements became Valentine's Day blended
with Pagan Traditions Cupid was included
a carryover from Roman mythology
symbolizing love the Roman god of love
over time the essence of lalia
transformed from Wild fertility rights
I'm glad that they're saying that
because that is true wild fertility
rights is what ensued into the more
romantic and sentimental customs of
modern Valentine's Day itself there is a
secret to this heart-shaped thing in
fact the ancient plant sfum is closely
connected to both love and the heart
shape and it was also used as an early
form of birth control and abortion Aid
in ancient times this comes from the
atlas
obscura and it says the Original Seed
pod that may have inspired the heart
shape this historical Botanical theory
has its roots in ancient contraceptive
practices surprise surprise huh
yeah that is
quite an interesting shape to to be
remembered as your contraceptive Aid
continuing on they also say about this
plant it is a modern-day sfum plant
named after its ancient analog the heart
shape with its rounded top and pointy
end is pretty innocent for a
graphic it lacks the rebal connotations
of a lipstick smack or the peach Emoji
but when using it to mean I love you we
may be calling back to something
slightly more risky an ancient
contraceptive this seal or this mold
that they have here in the stone or um
impression is a sirenian coin from the
6th Century BC with a sfum seed
imprinted in
it wow it's like perfect perfect heart
we're going to talk just about the
Valentine Day card why that came into
existence it'd be remiss if we didn't
start off by providing at least a
snapshot of St Valentine on the one hand
he's renowned as a patron as a patron
saint of Love and Marriage on the other
epilepsy plague and beekeeping he has a
dual personality of um both good and
evil and that's interesting you see of
that happen when you're talking about
Roman mythology or Gods this by the way
comes from the History Channel Sky
history and the second paragraph down it
says even the Catholic Church accepts
that St Valentine may be a conflation of
two maybe even three
individuals in
1969 the Roman Catholic Church removed
St Valentine from the general Roman
Calendar so as little is known about him
the basic story is that he was sentenced
to death by Claudius gothicus for
marrying Christian couples he was
beheaded outside the flaminian Gate of
Rome on the 14th of February
269 so what I do know is that um usually
in the occult they like to actually set
up dates to
remember pursuing their enemies and
suppressing others
and it it it definitely seems as though
that's what they're doing here there
could be a connection to them actually
calling not only I'm not going to
dismiss the history we've just looked at
from lub lubric Calia but they had
another reason on this day to set up the
14th of February as Valentine's Day to
Remember him and their killing of him
because he did this so also from Sky
history the dawn of the Valentine's Day
card there isn't much evidence that the
Feast of Valentine inspired the writing
of love notes until
1415 when the imprisoned French Duke of
Orleans wrote a romantic letter to his
wife citing Valentine from the Tower of
London this lack of cards is hardly
surprising as most of the population was
illiterate however it's evident from
Joffrey choser and William Shakespeare
both of whom refer to him in their works
that St Valentine was a familiar figure
in the Middle Ages it wasn't until the
victorians began to take advantage of
their literacy and the uniform Penny
post system that the sending and
receiving of Valentine's Day cards
became more popular though not all were
Declarations of Love Now that might be
interesting to find out that not all of
the Love Letters or Valentine's Day
cards were love letters but this is
where where we start realizing
that um St Valentine's was
known by many his like popular and
famous individuals of that day next they
say that there were Viner Valentine
wow to most decent people the thought of
sending degrading cards to someone you
don't like on Valentine's Day is
strangely obnoxious but it's been
claimed that about half of Victorian
Valentine's cards were either mocking or
downright insulting in
tone for obvious reasons not many of
these cards survived but a few examples
featured drawings and text mocking a
person for being bald an alcoholic
aggressive Indiscreet or even supporting
women's
suffrage one notable example featured an
image of an approaching locomotive with
the verse Oh miserable lonely wret
despised by all who know you haste haste
your days to the end to end this sketch
the quickest way will show you so they
mocked integrated each other with these
cards um they also had you know stinking
degrading um cards that they gave each
other but why would you do that why
would you even this is this is
particular card is actually suggesting
that you kill yourself
and so it's very disgusting in its
nature and I remember getting a few
cards that were like that in my um I
think they're out there in the
Valentine's Day cards that are
circulating they're you know made
already for you to get maybe it's Pooh
bear or whatever age you are that was in
like fourth grade but not all of them
were kind they were they're
very um teasing and mocking
so I didn't appreciate that when I was a
child but getting back to this um last
paragraph in another particularly
extreme example the Paul ma Gazette
reported this sorry of a woman sending
her arange estranged husband an
offensive Valentine it read in his anger
he purchased a revolver and meeting his
wife last night shot her in the neck the
woman lies in the hospital in a critical
condition I can't believe someone would
actually just write that as though
they're thinking that
morbidly about that having done to them
this also comes from the History Channel
and it says who created the first
Valentine's Day box of chocolates by the
1840s the notion of Valentine's Day as a
holiday to celebrate romantic love had
taken over most of the English speaking
world it was Cupid's Golden Age the
prudish victorians adored the notion of
courtly love and showered each other
with elaborate cards and gifts into this
love crazed fry came Richard Cadbury
Sion of a British chocolate
manufacturing family who was responsible
for sales at a crucial point in his
company's history Sion means a branch of
a British chocolate manufacturing family
Cadbury had recently improved its
chocolate making technique so as to
extract pure cocoa butter from Whole
beans producing more palatable drinking
chocolate than most Britain had ever
tasted this process resulted in excess
amount of cocoa butter which Cadbury
used to produce many more varieties of
what was then called eating
chocolates Richard recognized a great
marketing opportunity for the new
chocolates and started selling them in a
beautifully decorated boxes that he
himself designed so it's due to Richard
Cadbury and the
chocolates he designed having had the
experience from his family who's already
in chocolate
making so there you have it not to
mention that it releases oxytocin which
is like getting a hug so you feel loved
you feel happier and safe and so you
feel more like you're in love you feel
happier let's read on from that point it
was a quick jump to taking the familiar
images of Cupids and roses and putting
them on heart-shaped boxes while Richard
Cadbury didn't actually patent the
Heart-Shaped Box it's widely believed
that he was the first to produce one
Cadbury marketed the boxes as having a
dual purpose when the chocolates had all
been eaten the Box itself was so pretty
that it could be used again and again to
store
momentos momentos from locks of hair to
love letters the boxes grew increasingly
elaborate until the outbreak of World
War II when sugar was rationed and
Valentine's Day celebration were scaled
down but Victorian era Cadbury boxes
still exist and many are treasured
family heirlooms or valuable items
prized by collectors now you know you
should also know why the She Wolf why
those two babies in the in the
wilderness with nobody to raise them uh
where that comes from you have cupid in
there and you have the whipping
celebrations that would have occurred it
is a little bit more gruesome than they
show um from from what I read these men
usually were only wearing a covering for
their groin and their backside uh maybe
a loin cloth but they carried out these
sacrifices of the goat and the blood on
the knife cleansing it with the milk but
they also had taken that whip gone about
town and women were ready they were um
kind of exposing shoulders and backs and
and taking some of their clothing off to
be whipped very very into it and wanting
to be whipped and they wanted to have
some of that blood flow from them to
show that they'd been whipped by it
they'd been blessed by it and were now
fertile and their fortune and blessings
and luck were all to come and so there
would have been blood um splattering
and people being in a frenzy that kind
of seemed
erotic in nature as well and um
that's what's missing from this picture
is this kind of animalistic craze for
sex passion desire and um in doing so
calling it a guise of fertility and
blessings for the entire land to appease
the gods and so on and so as for me and
my house we will worship the Lord that's
all that I can say I've given you the
proof I've shown you where it all comes
from I hope you guys all enjoyed this we
have links to donate on our website just
click the Donate button on the top right
we have merchandise there if you go to
our shop if you feel led to give we have
other methods of payment apps that you
can use like And subscribe and I hope we
will see you again soon thank you
bye-bye candy truth
[Music]